part of what makes the marvel cinematic
universe fun is how plot lines pay off
over multiple movies but that doesn't
mean every storyline gets a proper
ending here are some that completely
disappeared
at the end of the incredible hulk tim
blake nelson's samuel stearns is coerced
into giving emil blonsky a medical
procedure that turns him into the
abomination as blonsky charges out of
stern's office he sends the scientist
flying into a wall and a small drop of
hulk's blood falls from a nearby table
onto a wound on stern's forehead the
man's head begins to bubble and just
like that the origin story of marvel
comic's villain the leader is put into
motion the producers of this project
were hoping stearns could return in an
incredible hulk sequel with the leader's
green skin and enormous cranium however
the incredible hulk didn't light the box
office on fire and there were also
rights issues regarding further solo
hulk movies leaving a reappearance by
the leader in limbo more than a decade
after the incredible hulk other
characters from the marvel cinematic
universe entry such as general
thunderbolt ross and even the
abomination have come back to play a
part in newer movies but the origin
story of the leader has never been
followed up on and it doesn't appear to
be something that'll get expanded on
anytime soon
in thor the dark world a comic relief
character got her own comic relief
sidekick darcy lewis jane foster's
humorous intern from the first thor film
got an assistant to help her lug things
around in the form of ian boothby the
two have a mildly conflict-ridden
dynamic throughout the adventure before
abruptly kissing during the invasion of
london by the dark elves ian's role in
the mcu was extremely short-lived he
like jane and all of thor's earthbound
cohorts did not return for thor ragnarok
sorry to hear that jane dumped you
she didn't dump me you know
i dumped her some mutual dumping in the
years since however jane foster has
managed to land a comeback in thor love
and thunder while darcy returned in one
division as a full-fledged doctor yet
darcy made no mention of ian the romance
and the character of ian altogether was
apparently just not meant to last very
long in this franchise
in the middle of captain america civil
war tony stark drops a bombshell on
steve rogers he and pepper potts are
taking a break after the character was
absent from avengers age of ultron due
to her duties to stark industries this
confirmed that stark was officially
single again thanks in part to his
non-stop adventures with the avengers it
was a significant development that also
helped explain why potts was suddenly
m.i.a from the franchise
pepper
we're taking a break but this
development was abruptly upended in
spider-man homecoming when pepper potts
not only reappeared but was being
intimate with stark as if nothing had
ever happened there was even a gag about
stark popping the question to potts in
lieu of introducing spider-man in his
iron spider outfit to members of the
press the sudden loss of pots in stark's
life never got referenced in the
following two avengers movies either
making this a strange unexplained detour
in the love life of two principal mcu
figures
in the wake of the avengers thor the
dark world fine scientist eric selvig
struggling to maintain a proper
psychological state having had loki
control his mind for an extended period
of time selvig is now fit to bouts of
strange behavior like wandering around
stonehenge naked he's even been locked
up in a psych ward which darcy and ian
must break him out of to assist thor in
his quest to defeat the dark elves the
lingering after effects of selvik
getting his brain scrambled in the
avengers wouldn't last forever when thor
went to recruit his help in age of
ultron selvig was seen walking out of a
college that he teaches at not only had
he returned to his regular day job but
he seemed to have fully recovered from
his encounter with loki
at the end of iron man 2 weapons
manufacturer justin hammer is arrested
by police officers as this happens he
calls back to pepper potts that it isn't
over with you i'm going to be seeing you
again real soon perhaps that was
originally the plan mcu films don't just
keep any villain alive and well after
all keeping hammer alive and thirsting
for vengeance had to be thought of as a
way to set up future installments
however for whatever reason hammer has
not reemerged in the mcu iron man 3 had
no place for hammer replacing him with
killian while other movies starring tony
stark like captain america civil war
also found no room for him the most
peculiar part of this is that rockwell's
profile has increased substantially
since iron man 2 came out having won a
best supporting actor academy award and
getting another oscar nomination in the
same category one would think marvel
studios would be scrambling to bring him
back instead rockwell's entire presence
in the franchise has been limited to
iron man 2 and a tiny cameo in the short
film all hail the king
in the incredible hulk viewers aren't
just introduced to the hulk they also
get a first glimpse of the franchise's
version of the romance between bruce
banner and betty ross this is a
relationship complicated by banner
watching out for his heart rate
quickening out of fear of turning into
the hulk this dynamic was established as
a crucial part of banner's life and was
even used as a signifier that there may
be more of banner in the hulk than their
appear however betty has never
resurfaced in the mcu despite her father
general thunderbolt ross managing to
re-emerge as a recurring presence in
recent entries in the saga the character
hasn't even been referenced again either
by her father or by banner instead
banner took up a romance with black
widow in avengers age of ultron which
seemed to close the book on this initial
love affair for the hulk's alter ego the
only post-incredible hulk nod to the
character in the mcu was through the
initial code name of the hulkbuster
armor ai in age of ultron being veronica
a nod towards the archie comics
character of the same name who had a
rivalry with a lady named betty
captain america the winter soldier ends
with a genuinely interesting beat after
faking his death earlier in the film one
would expect fury to just return to his
regular day-to-day duties by the end of
the feature instead fury makes the
conscious choice to remain deceased to
the general public the viewer even gets
a glimpse at his headstone in washington
dc cemetery as fury walks off screen in
the winter soldier the possibilities for
what he could be up to next are
limitless strangely then age of ultron
brings things right back to the original
status quo while initially fury is
depicted as someone who's been off the
grid for a while he's eventually shown
to be manning a helicarrier in his
traditional leather garb to help
sokovian civilians get to safety rather
than a shadowy individual believed to be
dead by most fury is once again a public
figure that everyone knows is alive and
well it's a strange move that undercuts
the ending of the winter soldier and all
the narrative possibilities that fury
remaining dead could have brought
in the initial guardians of the galaxy
movie xandar is an important planet it's
where four of the five titular
superheroes meet up as well as home to
the headquarters of the nova corps
organization and the backdrop for ronin
the accuser's massive final battle to
execute his vengeance against the
planet's occupants given all that and
the fact that it housed an infinity
stone at the end of guardians of the
galaxy fans might expect such a location
and its characters including nova prime
and roman day to reappear throughout
future mcu adventures particularly
cosmic-based ones instead the planet
hasn't reappeared at all in subsequent
films the nova corps gets name dropped
in guardians of the galaxy vol 2 while
zandar also gets mentioned in thor
ragnarok and avengers infinity war
that's the extent that this planet is
factored into the franchise post
guardians of the galaxy with even its
destruction by thanos happening entirely
off screen zandar started as a seemingly
important place but it's largely brushed
aside in the mythology of the marvel
cinematic universe
starting with the show's second season
bobby morse was a critical part of
agents of shield and its ever-expanding
mythology however she and her love
interest lance hunter eventually left
shield in the third season episode
parting shot in universe they were
forced to leave to keep coulson and
company safe however beyond these
fictitious confines morse's sudden
absence was done to allow herself and
hunter to headline a spin-off show
entitled marvel's most wanted they're
not coming back
they've been disavowed what are you
talking about there were no good options
however those plans hit a snag when abc
opted to pass on most wanted leaving the
two characters in a state of limbo
though hunter managed to return in a
guest appearance capacity in a later
episode of shield morse remained m.i.a
for the rest of the program's run part
of this appears to be due to scheduling
conflicts for actress adrian pilicki who
eventually found a lead role on the fox
sci-fi series the orville however no
official reason has ever been given for
her sudden departure whatever caused the
character's absence a whole was left in
the agents of shield mythology that kept
all storylines related to morse
awkwardly unresolved
for ant-man and the wasp the two titular
tiny heroes faced off not against thanos
or he who remains or ultron but rather
ghost a woman who can move through
objects and constantly looks like she's
glitching in and out of reality ghost
turned out to be a morally complicated
figure one who merely wanted to cure her
condition not to destroy the world while
she wasn't above doing bad things she
was also somebody whose life wasn't
defined by acts of malice a scene at the
end of ant-man and the wasp suggested
that she and her surrogate father figure
bill foster would be sticking together
for whatever came next but ghost has
ended up being absent so far from the
rest of the marvel cinematic universe
despite ant-man even name-dropping her
during the mid-credits scene of ant-man
and the wasp ghost has never appeared in
another mcu entry it also doesn't look
like ghosts will get her storyline
resolved in the upcoming ant-man and the
wasp quantomania either there's been no
news on ghost star hannah john kramen
getting cast in that film plus she's
committed to starring in red sonja
in the middle of spider-man homecoming
the young web crawler's inexperience
with properly handling criminals is made
apparent through the bungling of his
attempt to stop a weapons sale on a
ferry this transaction involves the
henchmen of the film's primary villain
adrian toomes aka the vulture but it
also entails matt gargan a criminal who
in the comics is also known as the super
villain the scorpion here gargan is
depicted as just a regular person albeit
one with a scorpion tattoo on his neck
he quickly vanishes in the chaos of
spider-man's botched attempt to stop the
crime the mid-credit scene of homecoming
in which a battered and vengeful gargan
confronts tombs in prison and asks if he
knows the secret identity of spider-man
seemed to be setting up the idea of
scorpion as a recurring threat to
spider-man however gargan has made no
further appearances in either spider-man
far from home or other sony marvel
productions like venom there's also been
no word on him appearing in future
productions like spider-man no way home
while a rumored presence in the future
silver and black went nowhere once that
film got canned in pre-production while
gargan was useful in showcasing spidey's
inexperience in homecoming the seeming
lack of interest in further exploring
the character indicates his usefulness
in the mcu may have come to a close
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite marvel movies are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one